you
the audience will not be surprised to
hear us advocating that you should get
yourself outside
get outside we have been saying from the
very beginning we have this is this is
you know this has been one of our drum
beats one of our mantras from long
before we were here before you talking
about any of this
and some of that is for reasons that we
can point to and some of it is for
reasons that we don't exactly point to
but allude to in many ways in for
instance hunter-gatherer's guide to the
21st century in which we say
you know what
uh there are things that humans have
been doing for depending on exactly what
system you're talking about and how long
you want to count thousands tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands
billions of years depending right
and some of those things we know uh some
of the pieces parts of what it is the
benefits are
but some of them are likely to bring
with them benefits that actually we
can't we don't yet fully know
we maybe can't even yet ever now
and if we try to disassociate the
benefits from the package in which they
have historically come to us
we may in fact
negate or even reverse the benefits
so getting outside i think uh turns out
to be one of these so i'm going to set
this up in sort of a little
somewhat counter counter-intuitive way
because it appears at first to maybe run
counter to some things that we've talked
about but i think ultimately it doesn't
uh so we will link to a youtube video on
the youtube channel medcram called the
vitamin d paradox and covered 19 and why
it predicts but doesn't always protect
now we of course have talked a lot about
the benefits of vitamin d
brett did an excellent uh conversation
with two
one preeminent vitamin d researcher and
someone who's a little bit more recently
to the game but you know they just they
had a ton of information and we've also
talked with them
and i've written up a fairly long thing
on my substance about the benefits of
vitamin d and why
unlike actually what we wrote in our
book
this is one of the few cases where we
think actually supplementation that you
know taking the little the peace and and
taking it into your body that way will
be beneficial uh and you know one of the
reasons that we argue
for our ch our change in opinion
is that unlike almost all of the other
things that you might supplement your
diet with uh those are things that you
normally could be getting from a whole
food nutrient dense closer to you know
its origin diet whereas vitamin d for
the vast majority of humans for the vast
majority of our history have gotten most
of our vitamin d from synthesizing it
through the skin from the sun
i'll add one thing yes i think we have
been perfectly consistent and i hope
clear every time we have discussed it
that even though we have argued in favor
of supplementation as something that is
quite safe and potentially useful and
for those of us who live in the
temperate zones very likely uh
beneficial because we tend to be
deficient strongly tend to be deficient
we have never once argued that you
wouldn't be better off getting this
through photosynthesis in the sun right
right so we've been clear about that the
basic point is failing getting enough of
it from the sun supplementation is
likely to be valuable that's right
uh so
uh
we have for instance i'm gonna just
say i'm gonna ask you to quickly show a
couple of things on my screen but but
then kind of go off of them quickly we
have a paper that finds
here
uh pre-infection
25 hydroxy vitamin d3 levels in
association with severity of covid19
illness if i may have my screen back
thanks i'm sorry i didn't get to
printing everything out this week so i
don't have a backup
which finds that
so that first paper finds that people
with low vitamin d levels before illness
are more likely to have bad covert
outcomes okay
we have a uh
rct uh here a randomized control trial
that randomized clinical trial that
finds here's the title efficacy and
safety of vitamin d supplementation to
prevent covet 19 and frontline
healthcare workers and they find that
yes there is there is a benefit to that
and um however we have another rct which
is the one the medcram video
shows uh and talks about
uh which is called here um
zach you can show my screen just briefly
this is a it's a pre-print it doesn't
look the same vitamin d supplements for
prevention of cover 19 or other acute
respiratory infections a phase 3
randomized control trial
and
what they find surprisingly is
conclusions of the abstract among adults
with a high baseline prevalence of
vitamin d insufficiency
implementation of a test and treat
approach to vitamin d replacement did
not reduce risk of all-cause uh ari
which it's going to be like acute
respiratory infection or copenhagen they
found that vitamin d baseline vitamin d
levels increased but that um
that um
that responses to other acute
respiratory infections or cova-19 were
not we're not improved so that runs
counter uh to the previous um rct
uh that i showed
and um you know there's there's a lot of
you know maybe there are other
contributing factors
maybe the fact that it wasn't very high
dosage vitamin d it was in like i don't
remember it's like 3 200 ius per day
they didn't give a bolus dose as dr
benskin has suggested is important
although the rct that did find a benefit
and the mexican healthcare workers also
didn't use a bolus dose there are a lot
of factors here right
um
but
it does seem like there may be something
additional going on and here i just want
to show
and actually zach if you could put up
that first screenshot that i sent you so
i've just got
um
yep so the files are numbered but they
should have come in in the numbered
order
uh and here we go uh this is from again
this medcram video that i will link to
as well
uh in which the um the guy talking his
name i've forgotten i apologize um says
okay being outside versus inside has
more than one effect it's not just about
uv and of course it's the uv
um light
that converts that basically
photosynthesizes although i'm always
nervous about using that term with
humans but the photosynthesizes into
vitamin d in the skin um in in humans so
yes we have if you're outside you have
higher uv and then you have more
production of vitamin d and um and that
is true also however when you're outside
you have higher levels of near-infrared
radiation exposure and what that causes
and i'm going to explain a little bit
more about this although i'm not going
to go into all of the all of the kind of
frankly exciting stuff that i've been
learning in the last 24 hours about this
um higher levels of intracellular
melatonin that's intracellular melatonin
which is different from the circulating
melatonin produced by the pineal gland
which is the the thing that we think of
when we think of melatonin when we think
of melatonin we think of it being
like the nighttime hormone
and it's circulating it's produced by
the pineal gland intracellular melatonin
is produced by mitochondria
and actually appears to mitigate and
modulate a lot of things about health
including respiration and metabolism and
homeostasis all right so i just want to
go evolutionary biologist here on this a
little bit
not surprising to see
the same molecule show up in two
radically different mechanisms because
basically the point is it's a signal
molecule and it works at a distance and
it also works uh in close proximity and
yes the the
physiology of the body can simply
you wouldn't expect it to come up with a
whole new signal because the point is
the signal has already evolved and it
can be repurposed and this is something
that actually we it's not infrequent to
see this kind of thing in fact
neurotransmitters
often
work on various different systems
and this is in fact yet another example
of how our reduction is thinking like oh
oh we figured out melatonin we got it we
know what it's for
okay i think we are correct that we know
one of the things that it it is for and
even that language makes me nervous but
you know apparent the melatonin that is
produced by the pineal gland that ends
up circulating does appear to be four in
quotes um
helping to modulate circadian rhythms
and sleep-wake patterns
but melatonin the molecule
when produced intracellularly by the
mitochondria and does not circulate
appears to be about cleaning up
like about about dealing
with antioxidants and basically involved
in a lot of of cellular health
uh that it's the same it's the same
molecule it's in a different place it's
produced in a different way under
different circumstances and it's doing a
different job and both of those jobs are
necessary for us but they're not the
same job so it cleans up
basically free radicals it clean that is
at least that is one of the things that
we now understand and by we i mean these
researchers who have not this is not
very old research yeah but this is
pretty new like we've we
the scientific community has understood
melatonin as like the sleep molecule
um circulating um helps in train wake
sleep cycles for a pretty long time and
i don't know if by long time i mean
decades or closing in on a century um
but this other
function of melatonin is is newer to us
the scientific community and and
humanity at large so i will just throw
into the mix here that one of the
uh those who have dared to generate
treatment early treatment protocols for
covid have had melatonin on the list and
it has been a head scratcher for me why
why would this be and in fact i think
they're going to have it right
yep in a previous live stream i think we
talked about the question of whether or
not that is an effect of the molecule or
it is an effect of the benefit of sleep
which is well understood to be uh an
important contributor to and is it
related that one of the main symptoms of
covid is deep fatigue
i don't know i don't i you know i don't
know which of these things might be
connected or not but it does seem like
there are a number of connections here
that's really interesting right also
raises interesting
welcome to complex system style
questions about so just like for like
i'm actually this is brand new to me but
it's even branded new to brett like
brett this is the first time i've i told
you i want to talk about this and i'm
not going to give you the
right i'm not going to tell you what it
says so this is brand new to you right
now brand new so the question then uh
is well a you there's certain things we
know now you might intuit from your own
experience but we know now uh from
scientific work that actually there's
certain elements of repair that require
you to be
dormant right right so that
you know the advice to you know take
lots of fluids and get sleep is about
more than just you know not having
better advice to give you but
it provides an opportunity to do things
and thereby you know not sleeping denies
your body the opportunity to do things
increases the risk of uh negative health
impacts but the question i guess is if
you were you know if you had a hormone
like like uh melatonin
that triggered sleep and there were some
aspect of
oxidant control that was better deployed
during sleep in other words if there are
you know a trade-off between you know
what your body prioritizes when awake
and therefore you know well so one one
of the things that i'm i'm learning and
this is again new to me even newer to
you but new new to me
is that um it is now proposed and there
is some research evidence to support
this that um basically
near-infrared radiation
uh triggers the intracellular production
of melatonin by uh by mitochondria and
it tends to produce an excess which is
then held in reserve for those moments
when there's not enough
and uh and
uh that would be consistent uh
potentially with what what you're
talking about um it would also
be
let's see i was just going to go one
other place but actually uh this may
prompt me to remember the thing i was
just going to say if you could show that
second
screenshot zach which should just be the
next one that i sent you which relates
um
to a decrease in full sunlight exposure
in humans from 1800 to the present day
so this this is extraordinary and this
is actually
borrowed you can for those of you
watching you see at the bottom the
zimmermann and writer paper 2019 which
i'm going to read to you a little bit
from
but this this screenshot is from the
medcram video and actually can you show
that on our smaller screen zack so i can
see it we have um
via the the two the blue and the red
blue is visible spectrum light and red
is near infrared spectrum light and one
oh i know one of the things uh that i
learned today is
that near infrared spectrum
light
a goes through clothes
and is highly reflective off of foliage
so even if you're dressed and in shade
if you are outside you are still getting
near infrared spectrum light if the sun
is up okay so this is this is not true
for uv for the most part right so what
we have done as humans is focused on
that which we can see right that which
we can sense and that of course is
defined exactly as the visible spectrum
we named it it's the visible spectrum
for us it's of course not the same part
of the spectrum that's visible for bees
and snakes and other things
but the visible spectrum is that which
we can see directly infrared being off
one side ultraviolet being off the other
side of it
both all of it though the
electromagnetic um
spectrum that we receive from the sun
is
brings value that we have only begun to
perceive so in 1800 uh we were getting
um i know that's this there's no y
you know there's no y axis on this but
you know two and a half times as much uh
near infrared
uh light as visible light because we
were out about 50 outside and we were
also getting it from campfires so
campfires give you near infrared as well
isn't that beautiful isn't that a lovely
a lovely little thing for us you like to
talk about campfire both literal and
metaphorical metaphorical campfire
doesn't provide you um infrared light
but but literal campfires do
by 1950s
it can make you hot under the collar
not the same thing though
really not
so by 1950
the
the visible spectrum light that
humans in you know presumably were
talking about weird humans you know
western educated industrialized rich
democratic etc
we're getting was lower
but also so was the near infrared light
on account of
uh we had we had light bulbs which we
didn't have in 1800 but they're 100
incandescent which do emit in near
infrared
and we were using plain glass windows in
our windows which let 25 or so of the
near infrared through and oh no that's
actually that's supposed to be on a
different line playing less windows
which let a certain amount i don't
remember the percentage of the near
infrared through and the estimate is
you're spending about 25 of our time
outdoors
by 1990 we've begun to move into
fluorescent fluorescent does not emit
near infrared
and we still got plain glass windows
which are letting some of the infrared
through and we're spending less time
outdoors and by
the present time we've got
um
100
uh visible only light bulbs with leds
and oleds and compact fluorescents so
incandesce we're phasing out
incandescents even though everyone knows
they feel better with incandescent
lights right and part of why they feel
better
i'm going to pause it and i'm sure this
is partially true is that because they
are emitting this near-infrared light
which we are completely deficient in we
now have low e glass windows which are
great if what your priority is is to
decrease energy loss and therefore
decrease your energy bills and you know
decrease how much we need to rely on
whatever your energy source is
but if energy cost is the only priority
and uh and it's measurable you can
measure how much energy loss there is
and no one has yet figured out as we
hadn't until recently this thing and who
knows how many other things we haven't
figured out how human health will suffer
as a result of low e windows what you've
done with the low e windows is you've
also reduced the near infrared light
that's getting through them to zero and
we're spending this estimate is roughly
seven percent of our time outdoors our
near infrared light
exposure
is staggeringly low
and if we go outside even if we're
clothed even if we're under some cover
we are getting near infrared light and
so at some level you know this i'm going
to continue to go on but
get outside like get outside and don't
assume that the vitamin d supplement
which yes especially in northern
temperate winters and southern temperate
winters the opposite time of year um are
likely to be helpful but it's not
the only thing that you should be doing
all right that's fine is your mind blow
like my mind is my mind is blown yeah um
i will say that one
you know if we keep saying uh near
infrared
then we sort of obscure what's actually
happening here which is that we are
getting more and more efficient
yeah the point is what do you mean our
technology in terms of our built
environment yes what i mean is you think
just like with with milk right what is
breast milk it's food hey we can replace
food with other food yeah well what if
it's food vaccines or vaccines peer
review is peer review
right exactly and so the point is the
joke
the joke all of us who've you know
worked on anything with a limited energy
budget the joke is that uh a an
incandescent bulb is a heater that
happens to put out some light right
right it's terrifically wasteful yeah um
and so i was like oh ow why like why did
i right just try to unscrew a bulb that
was just on
try that with an led it's fine well leds
are somewhere you know cfl's are
[Music]
first of all i should say as you know
i've been ranting about cfls for decades
these things were never green they are
efficient but they were never green and
they were never healthy
um they were a disaster and the idea
that people have had these things in
their homes and been breaking them and
releasing mercury and not realizing how
much mercury they just put into their
environment
it's insane right that was a con um leds
are way better but well i mean also i
mean this is another this is branding
like oh call it green you'll get a lot
of people to buy it's like actually
there are a lot of us who really do give
a damn really do care and are not buying
your you know your like tokenism of like
if we call it green you're gonna buy it
because we know you're that much of a
sucker well actually this goes to uh one
of your themes
you know the tyranny of metrics thing
which is to the extent that we can
measure something like how much coal has
to be burned at the plant in order to
make this light bulb put up enough light
to do your work the answer is yes cfl is
pretty good right if you were going to
do the equivalent of the all-cause
mortality thing it's a freaking disaster
right it misinforms your pineal gland it
puts mercury in the environment all over
the goddamn place um it messes up your
sleep cycles it's it's a disaster and as
it turns out it reduces your
access further to near infrared which is
uh important for dealing with the
oxidants that you are generating because
you got a crap diet and a bad lifestyle
which is also fed to you by uh you know
we moderns are living the greatest life
imaginable it's like in some ways yes
but that doesn't mean we have to buy
every
every solution that is handed to us
because many of them are bad and some of
them are bad and we don't know why yet
but if we are thinking
not sure about that one
maybe trust your instinct and think on
it more
[Music]